what's going on everyone alex ramosa
here
founder of jim launch allen prestige
labs
and owner of a couple other companies um
and today i'm going to talk to you um
about how to sell some stuff all right
so there's um there's there's three
types of questions um i think i've
talked in other videos about how
um how to structure your sales
conversations but i haven't talked as
much about the nature of the questions
and the types of responses that you're
getting
right and so in a sales process right
you're you have some questions that are
going to be
mining questions that's trying to
extract information from the prospect
and the remainder of the questions are
questions to get agreement right so
you're going to put a proposition out
there and ask for agreement
right and if you get enough agreements
it's going to be natural that they're
going to want to move forward working
with you
now the way that you structure these
questions all right
i would say that you have yes-based
questions you have
um neutral questions and then you have
negatively inclined questions
all right first time i heard about this
from chris voss he's the guy who does
the um
he wrote the book never split the
difference really interesting stuff
um and so a yes-based question would be
like sound great
yes that sounds great right a neutral
type of question would be like
fair enough does that sound fair does
that sound reasonable to you
right they'd be like well that sounds
reasonable now it's still technically a
yes-based question
but the question that we're asking has a
neutral tone to it
all right because we're not saying hey
is this the most amazing thing you've
ever heard of
like do you think this is the most
amazing program the amazing product
like blah blah that's asking a lot of
someone
right for them to agree to that so that
would be a harder yes to get
it's easier to get something like a a
reciprocal
yes which i would say someone says you
know that's a lot and we say
no worries what if we did this fair
enough they say well he made a
concession
that sounds fair or if we did this does
that sound reasonable
that's not like a fair expectation yes
it does great and then you can go to
close the sale
and if you've heard any of my past sale
stuff one of my favorite closes which i
got from
jordan belfort um is fair enough right
i just love this clothes so much because
it's like fair enough
right you make a concession fair enough
and so many times we were like well they
made a concession
and i'm a reciprocal human being it's
very hard for me to deny this request
and say yes i do believe it's fair and
then you say boom then let's move
forward right
but this is one that i learned very
recently um that i really like and i
when i look back through my actual
conversations i do this
and that's why i think it's so
interesting because
i'll i'm gonna i'm gonna be i'm gonna
level with you really quickly
all the people that i know who teach
sales are natural born salesmen which is
interesting
right they're natural born salesmen i
don't know a lot of people who
who teach sales who weren't naturally
very good at it quickly right um
and so there are some things that people
naturally do because they've
had a lot of experience doing it and
usually you get a lot of experience
doing it because when you start doing it
you get enough success that you can you
can steamroll
right um and grow and get a lot of
volume and then once you do lots of
volume then you can master at it but you
had some sort of inclination or
proclivity
towards the skill all right um that
being said it doesn't mean that anyone
else can't become a great salesman
it just means you might have to have
more reps to get there now that being
said
no base statements this is actually
where you
you go in opposition right and so the
reason and the psychology behind this
per my understanding and it makes
complete sense to me at least is that
people feel safer saying
no people feel like they retain their
autonomy they feel like they're
they're at ease it's harder especially
like you think about decision fatigue at
the end of the day people don't want to
be
responsible or anything they don't feel
vulnerable to saying yes and agreeing to
something right
instead they prefer to say no and stay
safe right
but if you phrase your questions
properly you can get people
to say yes by saying no which is one of
the most powerful sales taxes i shared
in a different video
where richard schwartz taught me how to
get someone to say yes by saying no hey
you don't want anything else do you no i
don't want anything else and by doing
that they got 95
of people to take an upsell all right
now no base question
this is something like would you be
opposed to moving forward today
would it be completely unreasonable for
us to get started at the end of this
conversation
um would it be a completely would it
would be completely out of left field
for me to say that we should start you
know start start working together today
um so it's all of these would you be
opposed to would you be against
would it be unreasonable right all of
those things are no based kind of
antecedents or
sorry precedence that that that lead
into a no base question
and so think about this if i said and
i'm going to give you the same
same kind of scenario here if i'm trying
to get my wife
to go where i want to go to dinner right
because i want to go to cheesecake
factory the finest establishment in the
land
all right count it get the cajun chicken
little so you can get them half grilled
and half uh
half a half right and get the get the
sauces from the thai lettuce wraps
anyways
um if i say hey babe you want to go to
uh cheesecake factory she might be like
well no i don't want to go to cheese
factory right or like i'm not really
sure
right now if i switched that and i said
would you be against going to cheese
factory
well i'm not against going to tca
factory and i'm like great let's go
and so that's the beauty of a no base
question see how different it free it's
phrased
right and if i say hey you excited to
move forward today that's a yes
right it's harder to get someone to say
yes i'm excited before today would you
be opposed to moving forward at the end
of the conversation
no i'm not opposed to moving forward
great and we get the sale
and so this is really interesting
because um
what i find because there's there's lots
of uh literature on you know getting
people to say lots of yeses and trial
closes and things like that throughout
the sales process
but in my mind these are all still ways
of getting agreement
which is the goal so it's simply using
psychology in terms of how people
like to respond to things how they feel
in the moment
of you know saying yes makes them feel
vulnerable saying no makes them feel
safe
and leveraging that now that that being
said it doesn't mean every single
question you have to ask
has to be a no based question but i
think if you if you can rephrase a
couple of the key milestone questions
that you have in your sales
conversations
or if you feel like you're kind of
closer to the edge with someone
leaning towards a no based question i
think is something that natural salesmen
do well automatically
like is it unreasonable for us to move
forward today right would you be opposed
to moving forward today would you be
opposed to knocking out the paperwork
should be opposed to
are you against xyz right oh no i'm not
against it all right let's rock and roll
right
um all of these are still ways to get
questions and so i think that in some of
my sales scripts right now
we're going to be shifting from fair
enough clothes drive is so wired in my
brain from doing it so many times
um to some no based phrasing uh because
it's easier to get agreement with
prospects especially even
if they're kind of fatigued at the end
of the day or which is when people are
less likely
to want to say yes to things um counter
example there could be decision fatigue
and they just want to say yes to
to get done with it right depends on the
size of the purchase
but anyways i hope this was valuable for
you in terms of phrasing behind the
questions
obviously this is not for mining based
questions where you're trying to extract
information from someone
um and to better understand this is
really where you're trying to get
agreements
um towards milestones to work together
all right so i hope this made sense
keep being awesome lots of love i'll
catch you guys soon bye